you toured with something that was
fantastically successful the United
Kingdom called the mighty boosh yeah and
it started out as a sort of a sketch
comedy group and the fascinating thing
is it kept morphing and growing and
became a radio show and then eventually
you started incorporating more more
music and then you guys became kind of a
huge like a rock band it was massive in
England yes is that a fair description I
could play anything though they haven't
go clue yeah we're here to educate this
show educate yeah yeah no it got really
big it was like we doing arenas and yeah
it got pretty rock'n'roll I think we
have a still here a picture of the
Mighty Boosh this is you guys yeah it's
sort of that pretty much encapsulate
everything and it got we had a gorilla
in our band on drums yes that's of
course yeah yeah well the thing is
people went absolutely nuts for you guys
and it got big to the point where you're
playing massive arenas you're in the
United Kingdom you're in a different
city every night how close did it get
for you personally to you feeling like
you were really living the rock and roll
lifestyle because you started out just
oh let's have a sketch comedy show and
it'll be done and then it turned into
this thing how rock and roll did it get
it go up for I thought I was Mick Jagger
for a little while yeah it got pretty
rough we gave Fleetwood Mac a run for
their money
I remember one night I got I just were
actually on tour I disappeared for two
days and you disappeared for two days
yeah not literally I'm not a magician I
where I went to a party and then I sort
of disappeared and when they found me I
was working in a shop went missing and
women you what kind of shop working like
a vintage clothes Thor yeah but
basically I got wasted to a group of
people when this girl said I can't I got
to go home I've got or open a shop at
9:00 in the morning and we all when
you're drunk you know we said yeah I
know don't we will all come with you
yeah yeah we're all gonna come with you
and then one by one everyone peeled off
and it was just me and this girl yeah so
when and we open the shot and then she
passed out on the floor I never you know
what to do so I just started working in
the shop customers are coming in yeah
customers are coming in in your ringing
up merchandise yeah and I had to sort of
move her behind the desk cause it looked
like I'd murdered her yeah I just saw
moved her behind the desk and I sat
there and Lee all these kids were coming
in going you know feeling I was gonna
know I just look like him yeah and and
the owner of the shop turned up and just
saw me and the girls feet behind the
desk she thought that I'd killed the
girl and I was just stealing her money
and I said no no I've sold loads of
stuff and I sold like a bag and two
Poncho's I did quite also I've never had
a real job so I really enjoyed it it was
nice y'all wanted to stay there forever
and then our tour bus sort of turned up
yeah I got a go now she said do I pay
you and I went no it's fine that's where
have you been and I went working in a
shop getting a job we're playing Wembley
tonight yeah but I've worked in a shop
you have a brief comedic style how would
you describe the new show that you're
doing I thought you were talking about
my personal starts gone a bit wrong
tonight I did a gig with Bobcat
Goldthwait and how did I look like I
just skinned Elmo I love America so much
I wanted to get my hair cut like TV
remote when I come here I think in
hindsight small Liza Minnelli for you
well this is my hairdresser thinking
like there's a cab hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography